[Music]
thank you everyone for coming down today
first of all my name is Andrew I've been
working in Google cloud for about four
years now I think this is the third time
we've run a GCP next event in San
Francisco and every year we've run it
it's really been a step change increase
in the number of partners the number of
attendees the number of launches and
more importantly the energy that we see
at these conferences it's really
gratifying to see it grow so much every
year so truly thank you for coming down
today and thank you for being a part of
that energy and a part of this
conference particularly thank you for
coming at this which is probably the
danger hour for a tech conference right
after lunch on a Friday so hopefully
we'll hopefully we'll be able to keep
you entertained what we're talking about
today is building high performance micro
services with go kubernetes and G RPC
and we actually realized when we were
working through the structure of this
talk we kind of started with the title
and we realized that you could almost
pick any single word in that sentence
and quite comfortably make an hour-long
talk out of it and in fact a number of
my colleagues are doing so even right
after this session we've got a Tim Hakan
is going to be diving into the the
details of kubernetes networking and the
latest there dancer-ly and sepal going
to be talking about a thing called Cloud
endpoints which I'll talk about a little
bit too but they'll be going deep on
that and then across the week we've had
a bunch of sessions on these topics that
have usually picked individual slices of
this and gone deep so we were trying to
think of what we could do to make this
interesting and we've realized that what
we could do is a complement to some of
these deep dive sessions with something
that was a little broader and a bit more
of an overview so what we want to do
today is show how you can use these
technologies hopefully you've heard of
some or all of them but we want to show
how you can use them in a real-world
practical grounded application so that's
what we're going to do today today we're
going to build
and deploy an application to the
platform that uses all of these
different services we're going to show
you a little bit about that process and
some some techniques and some strategies
you can use to turn that into a robust
workflow we're going to talk a little
bit about some of these technologies as
well and how they help us get there so
before we get into the app itself it's
worth just recapping a little bit of
motivation
hopefully micro-services is a term that
you've you probably heard before not a
new concept for the most part
fundamentally it's about taking apart
what might have previously been a large
monolithic codebase and breaking it out
into discrete components that can be
deployed independently and particularly
in the case there's a number of
advantages for doing this but it's
particularly advantageous when you are
building an application that has a large
number of developers on it being able to
independently deploy and manage and
implement each of these different
components unlocks the development
things from each other so that they can
so that they can work independently it
can be an enormous productivity boost at
Google were a very heavily micro service
driven company or service driven company
when you interact with a site like Gmail
for example when you go and view
mail.google.com you are triggering a
cascade of our pcs across Google's data
centers in order to retrieve the
information and serve you that page
there's a whole ton of work going on
behind the scenes and as you do that
your RPC is passing down through the
code paths that dozens and in many cases
hundreds of engineers have worked on so
for us being able to deploy these things
independently is hugely powerful so and
we've seen with cloud as well there's
been something of a resurgence and this
is a design 10 again for those who
around in the 90s service-oriented
architecture was another way of kind of
saying the same thing the general design
patent is not new but a combination of
elastic workload provisioning and some
of these technologies have helped
accelerate it and push it a little bit
further back into the mainstream
so we're single it's becoming a very
popular design plan a very useful one
especially in large organizations but it
comes with
a couple of important challenges and the
most perhaps the most immediate and
obvious challenges you know when you're
taking apart a codebase you know where
previously you were passing objects
around in memory now where as often is
not passing them across the wire so to
send a message we have a bunch of work
to take a take a request to serialize it
into a form that we can actually send as
bits down the wire that request that
needs to get to a network card that
needs to get translated into packets
those packets needs to get sent and
again there's many hours of discussion
you can have about that all of this then
needs happen in Reverse on the other end
the message needs to be deserialized
and then turn into something that an
application developer can use you know
some kind of in memory object that they
can actually work with to do that can
impose a significant performance penalty
it's obviously a lot more expensive from
a compute resources view to do all of
this work every time you send a message
and particularly when you look at modern
micro service architectures the maybe
can composed of many tiers and and many
different operations like fan-out the as
you as you push on this design pattern
this cost of serialization becomes more
and more acute excuse me so that that's
the first problem in concert with that
is another problem which is just network
contention part of this part of this
cost is just simply the amount of bytes
and bits you have to send over the wire
when you're dealing with significant
volumes of scale when you're dealing
with low latency or poor reliability
networks now our contention itself can
be a problem and if you're not careful
not having a good model on your network
architecture can impede your ability to
take up a design pattern like this I
mean finally as you're breaking these
things down into multiple components
usually you're breaking them down into
multiple processors multiple running
programs and when when you take
traditional models of application
isolation application containment and
apply that to micro services often the
simpler and agree of overhead that may
be practical for something that requires
a whole machine or several machines to
run but when you have a small service
that just takes up a couple of mega
memory maybe only needs a small amount
of spindle usage some of the traditional
models of managing the compute resources
that these services need aren't
necessarily as robust or as elastic as
we would like them to be and just to
emphasize that last point it's worth
mentioning bin packing and so this is a
somewhat simplified view of the problem
but in a traditional model of building
applications you know we we may have
separated our component we might have
separated our architecture out into a
few services but we will typically have
at least one machine dedicated to each
service or maybe a cluster dedicated to
each service and again that's fine when
the services are quite large it could
often justify several machines to to run
those but when you have a large number
of small services this model becomes
problematic
it's much more convenient if we can if
we can run two folds firstly run
services across multiple machines and
secondly run multiple services within a
single machine at Google this is a real
problem this is something we've we've in
Kent Wien started encountering a long
time ago as we had a large shared bulk
set of computer resources we've got a
large number of developers deploying
them deploying services into them we
wanted a way of being able to
efficiently manage how services were
being allocated to compute resource
without necessarily having to get into
the language of individual machines to
individual services so this fine grain
bin packing turns out if you can do it
turns out to be a real advantage when
deploying these kinds of systems again
not strictly necessary not strictly
required to couple this kind of
deployments to micro services but it
definitely helps you if you can so since
we've been doing so much of this at
Google and we've been doing it for a
while
we've spent a quieter with spent a
number of engineering cycles building
our technologies that can help us in
this process we're going to talk about
three of them today in many cases what
you're looking at are the second third
or fourth generation attempts at solving
these kinds of problems the first and
one of the most exciting is a thing that
we open sourced reasonably recently
called G RPC sense of Google remote
procedure call and G RPC is actually a
collection of libraries and tools
that allow you to create api's client
and servers in a number of different
languages and it relies on protobufs
which are a strongly typed and very
binary efficient mechanism for
serializing and deserializing messages
and it's also built as a transport on
GRP sorry on HTTP 2 so it's able to take
advantage of things like bi-directional
streaming and then on top of that is a
robust library for things like flow
control right management retries all of
the work that is ends up being necessary
and building a robust powerful client
but it usually takes a few a few
attempts and a few mistakes in order to
get right the other thing about it is
it's all open source second thing we're
going to use is go-go is the language
that absolutely has the cutest mascot
I'm sorry smallest runtime footprint the
and this again turns out to be important
especially when your services are small
and you have a lot of them it's not
against trickling necessary to have a
small runtime footprint but when you can
run your process as efficiently as
possible with as little memory and as
little system overhead as possible this
allows you to pack more and more of that
capacity into a finite amount of compute
which saves you money the other nice
thing about goal when it comes to micro
services it has a ton of interesting
features in the language but one of the
things that has that's important when it
comes to micro services is it has a
modern and efficient networking library
that goes a relatively new language
which means again it's been able to
learn some of the lessons of the past in
terms of just how networking can be
performed and abstracted and it's been
used very very heavily at Google for
networking applications and so we've had
a lot of time and a lot of energy spent
into making these libraries as efficient
and as optimal as possible
they're also nice and easy to work with
and again go is open source so there's a
community out there that you can you
know you can't just get it for free but
there's a community that you can engage
with and I don't want to make this too
academic a discussion or to académica
talk but it is we're talking a little
bit about performance the graph here is
actually from a public bench mark for
the G RPC team published they rerun this
benchmark with every release of G RPC
it's a thing called a ping pong test
where you have two V
and you just take a message serialize it
in a client send it to a server
deserialize it serialize it again send
it back and repeat I think it's about a
hundred times and measuring the the
latency of that process so it's a really
good measure of the the performance of
the the language in the runtime at
dealing with this message passing and
you can see go does really well here
it's approaching the kind of performance
you get out of C++ and also although
it's not on this list Java so while G
RPC is very much a language neutral
technology it works really well with go
which is why we like it the last key
piece in this is kubernetes again
there's a lot of talks right now on
kubernetes so I hope you leave you've
heard something about it
kubernetes is the the spiritual
successor in many ways to a technology
that we've been working on at Google for
a long time called borg borg is our
hosting platform that allows us to again
solve the bin packing problem taking a
large number of tasks so the large
numbers of google is submitting to a
system and it effectively acts as a
giant solver figuring out where is the
best place on my fleet to run that at
any given time and when these workloads
are not just being deployed all the time
but they're also dynamic in terms of the
resources that they need to have access
to being able to do being able to have a
dynamic automatic system that's able to
handle this allocation is hugely
powerful with kubernetes we've taken
that exact same philosophy and many of
the same ideas and we package that into
an open source project interestingly it
is itself written in go although like
like G RPC it's a it's perfect it works
perfectly well with with any language
it's very much a language agnostic a
piece of infrastructure also open source
and a very thriving community of people
are building around that as well and I
think more contributions of kubernetes
more commits have now come from outside
Google rather than inside so we are we
want to we want to build an app and show
how all of these things can fit together
if we can cut to the you can come to my
laptop quickly which I may need to wake
up so we're going to build an app the
app does this it creates 3d animated
gifs super practical I hope you can see
how this applies to your day-to-day
lives already
so super practical one of these apps
that is actually a little deceptive very
simple to use versa
to show but there's a lot going on in
order to make this happen I'll give you
I'll try this live and do my ritual
prayer for the demo gods but let's see
how this actually let's see what this
actually looks like to use this app so a
very simple form I'm going to put in a
name I'm going to choose a mascot you've
seen the go one again cutest right I'll
pick something else
say AGA PC will go create an app now so
we've now submitted a we've now
submitted a job we're using a technique
called path tracing to actually generate
that 3d gif which is a particularly
confidentially intensive exercise and so
in order to make all this happen we've
actually had to do a ton of work the
first thing we have to do is create a
series of scene assets to render that
image things like materials files object
files a bunch of metadata about light
sources and camera placements and we
actually generate that dynamically for
every single gift that needs to be
requested so we're going to create a
bunch of those assets the next thing
we've done is I create a task to render
each and every frame of that gift
there's about ten of them and so we then
submitted that and that we're done
especially faster than it took when I
practiced this we are so we've submitted
we have to submit a task for every frame
of this animation and then we've been
gone and dispatch that out to our
cluster our cluster is then gone and run
that rendering process it takes about
it's a pretty slow library that we use
so it takes about twenty to twenty
seconds to render each frame so it's
doing that in the background pulls them
all together and synthesizes them into
an animated gif so quite a bit of work
there just just to handle all of that
handle all of that overhead if we switch
back to the slides we we can dive into
the architecture of this thing and take
a look about how we actually built this
using these technologies so what we're
seeing here is the basically the set of
services that we needed in order to
build this out
would you believe five services are
needed to build 3d animated gifs so
let's break this down a little bit let's
start with the first service the
bottommost service which is the renderer
so the renderer is actually a very
general-purpose server
which is nice if we ever want to reuse
and give creation for any other purpose
what the render service does is take a
request that includes references to all
of those assets that we talked about so
again objects materials light sources
and so forth will perform the task of
actually generating an image it will
store that image in Google Cloud storage
and then it will return in the response
back to any upstream caller path to
where that single frame that single
image lives in Google Cloud storage on
the other side of this we have the
front-end service the front-end service
is the service that we were actually
interacting with directly in the browser
there this is the essentially HTTP
server so it's handling the formats
handling the form submission if we were
doing user authentication it would
probably do that and it does all the
kinds of things you would normally
expect to see in a in a web front-end
handle it you know serve static assets
and things like that there's not a lot
of logic in the front-end though we
really wanted to keep the logic out of
the front-end as much as possible
because we never know if we might need
to be building front ends for other
things maybe there's a mobile kiosk we
want to build or a mobile app that we
want to build that doesn't necessarily
need to talk to a HTTP API so we really
wanted to try and encapsulate as much of
the business logic if you will of the
gift creator into some other service so
we call this of course to give creative
service gift creator is does everything
in between our web front end and our
renderer gift creator takes a has an API
of its own
it takes an API request that looks a lot
like that form that you saw before so
there's a caption you can pick a mascot
there's a couple of other little bits of
metadata and it will when it receives
that it will then do all the work that
we talked about it'll be creating the it
will be creating the scene assets it'll
be storing them in Google Cloud storage
it will also be responsible for calling
out to the render service so it will
call the renders render zone API and
perform the fan-out in order to make
that happen we want to do that robustly
so we've we've actually split this into
a server and a worker and we use Redis
as our state management service to to
track the status of
all of these jobs give creator handles
all of that it actually has a its RPC
and its response it doesn't send back
the gift because we expect this process
to take a while instead we send back a
job status which the upstream front-end
can pause for is necessary in order to
see whether where this work is that so
cube tree is really the kind of the
workhorse of all of this of course gift
trader also does that synthesis the
compositing are the set of frames once
they've all been rendered into a final
image so a lot of work going on here I'd
submit on the AP is for a second there's
really two AP is that we have for the
two different services the render API
and the gift creator API we've talked a
little bit about what those API is do
but let's jump into a little bit of code
we wanted to write these API Xin Jie RPC
again we like the fast serialization the
efficiency on the wire we like all of
the retry and flow controller G but G
RPC gives you G RPC API is typically
start with a document that looks a bit
like the one you've got on screen here
this is a this is called a profile a
profile is actually a language agnostic
domain-specific language for describing
an API and it's describing two things
both the the are pcs which endpoints you
can call most crucially though it's also
describing the messages that get passed
in the request and the response and the
takeaway really from this screen is that
these days this this document is a very
it's quite strongly typed you can see
we've got things like enums here we can
describe quite complex quite complex
data structures although we haven't had
them here we can have things like
repeating fields and arrays and so it's
a very it's a robust language for
describing message passing now as I said
this is language agnostic although it
looks a bit like God code it isn't but
what this then it can be used for is two
things one is it's a fairly human
readable contract for describing what
this API should be then in itself is
actually pretty useful to different
teams who need to talk via an API can
use this document to effectively
negotiate on what it is that the what it
is what what are pcs they need from each
other and what information they need
from each other especially when they
work in different languages having a
which neutral document like this can
actually be a really a really nice idea
the second thing that we get out of this
document though is a is an input for a
tool called proto C so proto C is the
protocol buffer compiler and what proto
C does is take this document or a
document like it and can turn it into
clients and server libraries in your
language of choice I think for memory we
support about seven different seven
different languages at this point and
certainly go is one of them
I won't demo it to a Hugh here but when
I run proto C over a file like this I
then get a library generated which I can
then use in my code so this is some
actual code from the gift creative
service it's a little cut a bit out but
this gives you an idea about how this
generated code from a proto file can be
used in my service and if you've worked
with really any kind of point server
interface this will look fairly familiar
there's a lot of options and things that
you can play around with that we you
don't necessarily need to deal with by
default but you can certainly get into
you things like injecting middleware
things like supporting different
different forms of authentication but
fundamentally it's a very simple
particularly in go construct to work
with and crucially in this you can see
that the objects that I'm dealing with
in my go code are go objects I have go
structs I have go arrays I have go
strings so I'm working in a form that's
pretty idea Matic and pretty pretty
natural
I haven't had to deal with any of the
serialization and deserialization JP
sees handled that for me so now I will
get back into the code in a second but
one of the things that we found really
trips people up it tripped me up a lot
when I was first getting to first
starting to work with these tools it's
actually building the pipeline that gets
us from code like you saw before to
something that's actually running up
inside kubernetes it's complex because
frankly there's quite a few different
steps involved and there's many
different ways of accomplishing those
steps there's not necessarily one single
blessed path that everybody uses so we
wanted to talk about that a little bit
not to show the canonical way
necessarily but a way where we can get
from a code base to something that
actually runs
as I said there's a lot of steps the two
key steps the two high-level steps if
you will the the bills and packaging
phase this is about taking code and
turning it into a an image of binary
assets typically that's a darker image
but you can pick your pick your
packaging format of choice and you'll
usually store that in an asset registry
somewhere maybe it's artifactory or
docker hub or you can use we're going to
show Google Cloud repositories which is
sorry Google container registry which
comes with every every Google cloud
project second stage is about deployment
I've built this asset that describes
everything I need to run I then need to
get it into kubernetes and deploy it so
let's double click on that first stage
this is what the build pipeline looks
like for going from source to an image
for all this apps that we just showed
you and there's actually quite a few
different steps in there and the this is
especially true when you think about
compiled languages like go or C or Java
it's a lot more than just getting some
code up and running on a server we
really actually rely on these pipelines
in order to be able to in order to be
able to do it the first step is getting
the dependencies involved pretty
straightforward go for those of you who
are go developers you'll know there's
plenty of dependency management tools in
this case we use collides although this
I encourage folks to check out depth
which is getting a lot of traction but
you use a package management tool of
some kind to bring in all the necessary
dependencies that you have a new
application anything you haven't checked
in particularly important if this is on
a CSCI server or it's a cleanroom build
of some kind the next step is you need
to actually build your binaries you need
to run go build now in our case we have
three services that are actually
building ourselves so we have three
binaries one for each of them in our
case all of these binaries come from the
same codebase and we're just going to
package them into the same image we're
just going to invoke that image
differently for each service now you
don't have to do it this way again you
could have separate binary separate
images even different languages for
every different service here but for
convenience we packaged it into one and
we're Google we like them
Rico thing I guess but you have three
binaries and then we have these binaries
we need to get them we need to package
them into an image so in that image this
image is this hermetically sealed unit
that contains everything we need in
order to be able to run our app so
obviously we need to binary is in there
we don't need the source code we don't
need the build tools but we do need a
few other assets the web server for
example needs images CSS files templates
a bit of extra stuff in order for it to
work
the gif creative service needs you know
canonical copies of all of its asset
files so there are a few resources in
there that are necessary is in addition
to the binaries in order for this thing
to run and then once we package it we
need to get this thing into into a
registry somehow now when most people
start off with this usually what they
end up doing is building you know
usually some kind of I don't know shell
script file or some other tool to help
coordinate all of these steps and bring
them in together and that works pretty
well although you want you do run into
some challenges with that model one of
them being you actually need copies of
all of these tools running wherever
you're running that script in order to
run the build process so we found at
Google a lot of teams have this problem
as well a lot of our customers have this
problem so we've come up with a tool
that helps
it's called container builder we shipped
it a couple of days ago actually
container builder does exactly what it
says on the tin it takes source code and
packages it into a docker image and it
supports a language for describing these
kinds of pipelines that we've talked
about it's called it's a yam all syntax
the file is usually called cloud build
yamo and again I won't dive into the
details here except to say that we in
the we have a cloud build yam or file
for this project we've checked it into
the same repository that we have all of
our other code and this describes the
three steps that are necessary in order
to build our app everything is included
in this file the way we describe steps
in container builder is actually with
docker images themselves so the nice
thing about this file is it it can
actually be taken and run by anyone else
on my team even if they haven't
necessarily install all the tools like
glide and go and docker before so it's a
pretty neat way of describing a build
process
and it's pretty general-purpose again we
chose things like glides and go bills
and dock a bill to package everything
but you can pick up at the tools if you
wanted to practically how do you
actually trigger a build like this
you've got two ways one is of course
there's a g-cloud command to do it but
and that can be done from any any source
tree that's sitting on your laptop but
we also have and again this was just
launched a couple of days ago an
extension to contain a registry called
build triggers which allows you to watch
any github any bitbucket
any google source repository that you
might have set up and every time you do
a commit to a particular branch or a
particular tag or that follows a
particular pattern you can automatically
trigger a new build in container
registry so I'll give you a quick demo
of that now hopefully you can see this
I'm looking at Google source
repositories here this is the source
code of all three of those services jump
into front-end just to give you a sense
of it the front end is the code code
that produces the binary for the front
end some static assets in there it's the
templates and a few other little things
if we jump back out and look at the root
folder here we're looking at the master
branch we've also got some some pretty
familiar looking files that help us with
the build process so here's a glide file
that describes all of that dependencies
here's the cloudbuilt file where we
showed you a couple of seconds ago and
we've got a wedge tool to go with docker
file here - I mentioned there was a
packaging step we're using docker
to perform that packaging and so that
it'll pull from this docker file and you
can see there if you're familiar with
though if you're not familiar with daca
files this probably won't mean much to
you but if you are the interesting
takeaway from this docker file is
there's really not that much going on
all it's doing is copying in the
binaries that we built upstream and
adding the templates and a few other
things it's creating some root
certificates but otherwise it's really
not doing very much it's a last-mile
packaging step and this is really nice
it allows us to keep all of our build
tools out of our final image and allows
us to create something that really only
has the bare minimum we need in order to
run it so down here in cloud shell
hopefully you can all see this
so this is a this is a local VM I've
checked out you can see that same
repository so I'm going to try and make
a quick change here and for the sake of
this demo I'm going to make a boring
change I'm just going to jump into the
front end and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make that heart that uh I'm
going to make that form that you saw in
the first the form that you fill out to
create a gift I'm just going to change
the color of that just to prove that we
can just approve this deployment flow to
us so look at that it's a form dot HTML
okay we have a header here I'm gonna do
something really trivial I'm just going
to add something like that so I made the
change simple let's commit that back to
our repo
okay so we push that so now if you'll go
to container registry we give you some
room we jump over to container registry
you see here we have this list of build
triggers so we've set up a trigger
already to watch that repository and
every time we push to the master branch
it's actually it's going to
automatically trigger a bill for us
which I'm going to build history here we
can see that build is actually kicking
off and I won't bore you with too much
of the detail here except to say here's
the logs of the process so right now
it's going through that the glide it's
running glide to bring in all the
dependencies and then it'll continue on
with the build and the remaining steps
something interesting to note here is
that every build is given a build ID
this is just a UUID and in our cloud
build file we've actually let me show
you that really quick in our cloud build
file we've actually configured it to
generate our docker image with a tag
based on that build ID so we've asked
insert the build ID into the final image
let's jump back that might be done by
now and it is so there's our build and
if we jump into container registry and
look and we have a new image great and a
just quick look at the size of that
image it's only 15 megabytes and if
you're used to dealing with you know
docker images build from a bun to that
have a ton of tooling in them 15
megabytes is nice and small so now we
have an image next we want to get it
into next we want to get it into
production so now we want to talk about
deployment before we do that though so
you'll notice again this thing has a tag
based on its build ID for kubernetes
this can be really useful because we're
going to use the we're going to use
these tags in our deployment manifest
now we could use the UUID that I got
created here but that's a lot to
remember lots of type so I'm just going
to add a second tag here called demo six
which we can which we can use a little
later when we're building out some when
we're doing a deployment so if we can
jump back to the slides let's just talk
about how what this deployment actually
looks like so so what does this thing
actually look like inside kubernetes
pivoted it has a number of constructs
that are really useful in this process
and again it could be an easily an hour
talk just describing the different
moving parts of Cuba Nettie's that come
into play when you're running a real
service we're really only going to talk
about two of them the first is
deployments so a deployment is a is a
concatenated object in kubernetes that
actually in turn describes a number of
other underlying construct a replica set
and pods and pod configurations and it
just provides a really nice declarative
way of describing how all of these
things are constructed fundamentally
what a deployment is doing is telling
cuban it is how to run this image how to
run this code and in inking and if we
have an example of what a deployment
looks like this is example slightly
simplified deployment spec what this
deployment is describing is take a take
an image that we have sitting in a
registry somewhere run that image using
this command so this is the front end
service here so where we want to call
that front end binary that we built the
for describe any other metadata this
thing needs so what ports does it need
what environment variables does it need
you can describe other constraints like
how much meant what's the minimum amount
of CPU this thing needs how much memory
does it need but fundamentally pretty
simple
and how many replicas do we need how
many copies of this process do we want
running across our cluster the other
component is services so it's going to
get a little meta but we're going to
build services for services so a Cuban
it is service is a way of just providing
a simple static endpoint that we can use
when we talk that used to help us in
talking to all these different
components with deployments
we might be describing a number of
different processes running all over our
cluster we need a way of being able to
discover where they are and being able
to get traffic to them so a service in
kubernetes helps us do that the way you
can use a service really depends on your
deployments it's a very flexible it's a
very flexible descriptor in our case
though we have the three services we're
building all work basically the same way
we want to have a a stable internal DNS
name for each of them so that if we need
to refer to them from another service
inside kubernetes we can just look it up
by its DNS name and then what we want is
a load balancer which can dynamically
route traffic to any of the the pods ie
the running versions of this process at
any one time so this manifest file
describes everything we need in order to
be able to do that and we have one of
these for each about services we also
have one for the Redis service that
we're running inside cribben edges as
well so now we're going to run a another
quick demo so if we get such great so
we've built this image let's get that
image into kubernetes so in our source
tree we have this directory KH and in
our KS directory we have a set of EML
files that describe these deployments
basically the same thing you just saw on
screen now we have a we have three
services and each of those has a
deployment manifest and a service
manifest so in our case what we want to
do is update the front-end and really
all we want to do is tell that front-end
service instead of pointing to the old
image now we want you to redeploy we now
we want you to be running the new image
so if I increase this a little bit and
jump into that file
you can see here is the file
I like environment variable so I've
created a bunch of them for this project
and this here is the image that's being
used to render the front end you can
incidentally run multiple different
images inside a single multi-core pod in
kubernetes parlance but in our case
we're just going to do one and we're
going to we're going to we're going to
pull from a different tags than the one
we did previously and I think it was was
it what was it again was a demo six yeah
demo fix okay so we've updated that file
and now we need to tell Kuban it is now
we need to tell Kuban it is to deploy it
so let's go do that
okay deployment replaced now it's worth
unpacking that last section a little bit
because a lot just happened
we didn't tell kubernetes that we wanted
to replace an image what we did was tell
kubernetes that we want we would like
the state of the system to change to
match this new file and one of the
things that's different in a new file is
the image has changed it's kind of
important that we described it that way
we didn't say make a change we just said
we have a new idea of what we want the
state of our system to be kuben it is go
and figure out how to make that happen
now we can provide hints as to how kuben
it is can make that happen
like deployment policies but the end of
the day this is kubernetes
responsibility to figure out how to make
it work and this is again a really
powerful idea in kubernetes that you can
declaratively describe the state of your
system and have kubernetes figure out
all the funny details about how it
should actually work so let's let's
actually moment of truth here see if
this actually worked so I'm going to
jump into our kubernetes dashboard you
can see again all of the deployments
this is our running cluster this is
running across ten nodes which might be
a little excessive for a gif creator
we've a front-end deployment here and we
can see a minute ago this thing receives
a new replica set so a replica set is
the so what kubernetes did in the
background was create a new replica set
that describes the set of running pods
that we need this new replica set would
have the new pod configuration in it a
with a new image and it will spin up
that it will gradually increase the size
of that replica set while spinning down
the old one and so what you get is a
graceful deployment as we shift from
from one mode of a system to another
mode of the system so that actually
happens in our case it's a pretty simple
system and we're not really doing much
in a way of health checking or any other
thing that can potentially slow this
down so in our case it just happened in
a second or so but we have now a new
replica set and you can see here it has
two pods in them
pods aren't doing very much yet but if
we jump into one of them
we can see that this is now running with
a new image and it looks like it started
perfectly well so now we go back to our
gift creator we go back to that entry
form our text is in red so our change
went through so that is hands-down the
biggest applause I've ever got for
changing a bit of CSS so thank you for
that
so now we have so now we have a running
app running in a cluster I'm going to do
we want to go a little bit of time left
and I want some for QA so I'm going to
do a whirlwind tour of some of the
things that you get when you run the
stuff inside Google Cloud everything
I've shown you up until now for the most
part with the exception of Google Cloud
Storage perhaps you can run basically
anywhere in fact most of it you can run
on your laptop if you want to and again
all the stuff is open-source that's
pretty nice it means you don't really
need to pick Google in order to get
started with this stuff but if you do
happen to be running it on the platform
you get a couple of interesting
advantages the first of course is you
get Google container engine which is a
takes away a lot of the headaches of
actually running a kubernetes cluster it
can do a lot of things for you including
automatically patching nodes
automatically standing up say Google
cloud platform log balances in order to
make your service run it can do dynamic
it can do dynamic auto scaling a bunch
of other nice plug-in features there and
it takes a couple of clicks to use but
there's a couple of other features that
turn out to be pretty powerful on the
cloud platform that are worth are worth
touring through briefly we saw container
builder we saw source repositories we
saw the sort of the container registry
we also have a built in tracing system
which works really well with kubernetes
and G RPC so this thing I won't bore you
with some of the I won't bore you with a
full tour of this but this allows us to
do distributed tracing across a cluster
distributed tracing is actually a really
really useful in situations like this
you know one of the first things that I
want to do once I deploy this app was
figure out why it took so long for us to
render a bunch of frames so by jumping
into tracing you're able to understand
even as a job progresses where the time
is being taken is it being taken up in
render
during or passing this cloud storage or
is it in the gold binary distributed
tracing allows you to instrument your
code and when it's distributed the nice
mark the nice a nice artifact of this is
you can you can pass trace context
across multiple running processes geo PC
in particular makes it really easy to do
that but by doing so you can actually
die trace a request all the way from
when a user requested it on our front
end down through to the the found out
tasks that were being run in the
renderer and all the way back up to the
the final and the final job I want to
know that now but would make for a good
follow-up talk incidentally what you're
looking at right now is the is the
breakdown of latency over time you can
see there's a few experimental
tasks there which took a really long
time to run and generally you've got a
clustering that looks a little bit like
what you'd expect some of these dots
represent our front-end service which is
really fast and responds to requests
very quickly terminates very quickly
some of these represent spans of longer
jobs ieg the entire process of rendering
an image end to end or just calling the
render service which takes a bit more
time too so we have tracing of course
logging is centralized and we jump back
to the slides I'll cover a couple of
other quick nice features of the cloud
platform the other one is the live
debugger so if you want to if you want
to do real-time introspection of
application state the stack driver
debugger now allows you to do that it
works really well with go and it works
with kubernetes the other thing is
Google Cloud endpoints if you're not if
you haven't heard of Cloud endpoints and
you're interested in this dancer really
is giving a talk on this right
afterwards what Cloud endpoints allows
you to do is to provide some additional
robustness and automation and
centralization around around your API s
happens to work really well with G RPC
and this gives you features like a
dashboard for detailed logging of RPC
traffic for details monitoring of your
RPC s and Layton sees again across the
system if necessary
and things like centralized access
control so if you ever get to a point
where you're thinking about publishing
one of these API is to make them
consumable for the rest of the world all
of those things that you might need to
think about like
user-based quota ring and a coal
management Cloud endpoints grossly
simplifies the process of building out
and again works really well with G RPC
[Music]
[Music]